oh
donc ils ont pris environ 20 dollars et
une vieille montre monsieur 25
vous avez pas tenter un swing nom aurait
pu les éclater papa pareil ça chauffait
chez vous cette nuit [ __ ] j'aurais
bien aimé qui viennent chez moi
pourquoi tu les appelles démoli
j'aimerais essayer de limiter la casse
ah ouais tu vois ça comme ça toi ça va
comme tu veux parce qu'on dirait pas il
ya une part de moi que je retiens qui
crèvent dans vite explosé pourquoi ton
cola le vioxx
je vais vous [ __ ] une branlée
[Musique]
ça a été une sacrée journée je vois ça
pendant douze ans j'ai travaillé pour
des gens très dangereux
tout le monde descend sous sol qu'est-ce
qui se passe
d'appels surtout pas la police j'étais
ce qu'on appelle un contrôleur
le dernier gap tu as envie de voir
débarquer chez toi
parce que ça veut dire qu'ils 13 peu de
temps à vivre
mais j'ai tout plaqué pour avoir une vie
de famille
1 quand j'y pense peut-être même un peu
trop fun
en raccrochant vous avez laissé une
dette qui doit être repensée et votre
créancier est au courant de votre
résurrection
[Musique]
ils s'en sont pris à ma famille ils ont
volé mon bracelet le petit chat sept
petits comme méthode
[Musique]
tu me donnes tout de suite pensé avec
deux licences
tu as une sale gueule ah bah tu pourrais
voir les hauts de gamme
mais vous êtes qui moi je suis un no
body
[Musique]
hu